One of our classic
problems to analyze
using Newton's second
law is the motion
of two blocks with a rope
that's wrapped around a pulley.
So imagine we have a pulley, P,
and we hang from that block 1
and we hang from that block 2.
The pulley is suspended
by another rope,
and it's attached to a wall.
And let's now try to
use Newton's second law
to analyze this motion.
Now, going back to our
methodology, the first thing
we want to ask
ourselves is to identify
what are all the moving pieces?
So I'm going to make my
first assumption here,
that the rope/pulley a
surface so that's right
here is frictionless.
Now, what that assumption
means is that the pulley
will remain at rest.
And therefore, when we want
to break this problem down,
our first question is to
identify all the moving
objects.
And so we really have three.
We have mass, which we
label by 1, 2, and the rope.
So our goal now is to identify
all the moving objects
and to draw free body force
diagrams for each moving
object.
Now, one of the things
that I'm especially
interested in talking about
is to keep in mind to identify
action-reaction pairs.
So as I go through and draw
these free body diagrams,
we want to ask
ourselves, what forces
form Newton's third law
action-reaction pairs?
So what I'll do is I'll
start with object 1.
Now, I'm object 1 has a
gravitational force M 1 g.
And the rope is
pulling object 1 up
with the tension at the
end of the rope T rope 1.
So the action-
reaction pair to M 1 g
is the Earth, is the force
of this mass on the Earth,
which we're not considering.
What about the rope?
So now, let's draw a
picture of our rope.
And mass, this object here
is pulling the rope down,
and so we have, on the rope,
object 1 pulling it down.
And this is our
action-reaction pair.
What are the other
forces on the rope?
Well over here, object 2, t
2, is pulling the rope down
with the tension at
the end of that rope.
Now, also, the pulley
is exerting a force
on the rope upwards,
because we have that force.
And so these are the force
diagrams on the rope.
Now, what about the
action-reaction pair
to T 2 rope?
Well, let's continue and draw 2.
We have, again,
gravitational force on 2,
the Earth is the
action-reaction pair.
The force of 2 on
the Earth upwards
is equal to m 2g of
the Earth downwards.
We're not drawing the
Earth in this picture,
so we don't show it.
Now, here is the force
of the rope on 2.
And there is our other
action-reaction pair.
So these are Newton's third
law pairs in this object.
Now, now that we've
identified all the forces,
we want to apply
Newton's second law
to each of these
objects that are moving.
So let's begin by remembering
that if our rope--
our next assumption
here, it's assumed
that the mass of the
rope is very light.
And then the tension in
the rope is constant.
And the implication of
that is T 2 r equals t 1 r.
And that's why we can
now identify this as T
and that as T.
Little bit later on, when
we talk about pulleys
that have mass with
friction between them,
the tension on the two
sides of the pulley
will not be the same.
But for the moment, we've
made these assumptions,
and that holds.
And now, we just really have
objects 1 and object 2 analyze.
And so one of the
things that helps a lot
is, we need to choose
unit vectors in order
to write down the vector
equations for Newton's
second law.
So let's just here
assume for ourselves
that M 1 is greater than M 2.
This gives us some feeling
for how the system moves.
I like to do this
because it gives me
a way to choose my
unit vectors to make
all the accelerations positive.
So when M 1 is bigger than
M 2, I expect M 1 to go down
and 2 go up.
And that's how I'm going to
choose unit vectors j hat 1.
Now, here is the very
interesting thing.
We choose a separate coordinate
system for each object.
So I'm going to write that down.
We want to choose separate
unit vectors for each object.
And our accelerations
will be with respect
to those unit vectors.
This is where a lot of
people get tripped up.
So here, I'm choosing j hat 2.
And when I choose
that, I expect a 2
to be positive
because 2 is going up
in the direction of j hat.
And here, I expect a
1 to be positive also,
because 1 is going down.
Now I can draw Newton's
second law on 1.
So I have F 1 equals M 1 a 1.
And now I analyze my forces,
M 1 g is in the positive j hat
direction, t is in the
negative j hat direction,
so I have M 1 g minus
t equals M 1 a 1,
which I'm expecting
to be positive.
And in the same way, on
2, F 2 equals M 2 a 2.
I look at my force diagram.
Now, notice, j hat is
up, so t is positive
and 2 g is minus my direction,
and 2 g equals M 2 a 2.
So I now have two equations, but
when I look at these equations,
I see that I have
three unknowns.
I have t, a 1, and a 2.
But I have a constraint,
because these objects are moving
together and the way I've
chosen the coordinate systems,
a 1 is equal to plus a 2,
both are positive with respect
to my choice of
coordinate systems.
And so these two
as are the same.
And now I can solve my
equations for t and a.
And let's quickly do that.
M 1 g minus t equals M 1 a.
And over here, let's
solve for the tension,
for the accelerations here.
T is equal to m 2 a plus m 2 g.
And when I substitute
the t into that equation,
we'll find some space for that.
we'll write that as, if I put in
the M 2 minus M 2 a minus M 2 g
and bring the M 2 a
to the other side,
then it's a little
bit of algebra,
but I think you'll trust me
that this is M 1 minus M 2
g over M 1 plus M 2.
Now, we're almost done.
We need to check our answers.
First off, does it have the
dimensions of acceleration?
Answer, yes, mass
divided by mass,
g has the dimensions
of acceleration.
So that's my first check
always with my algebra.
Second check, what if
M 1 is equal to M 2?
Then the acceleration is 0,
I expect them to be balanced.
I've said that M 1
is greater than M 2.
Positive sign, my A is positive.
That's how I set up
my coordinate system,
so I expect that too.
By the way, our symbol
a was equal to those.
And so I'm pretty confident
that my result is correct.
And that's how we apply
Newton's second law
to the pulley with
several assumptions,
frictionless surface,
massless rope.
And think about how we
chose our unit vectors.
Each object gets its
separate coordinate system.
I'm not using the
same coordinate system
for each object.
I could've, but
then there would be
a subtlety to this
condition, the accelerations
would be opposite in sign.